Cancer is made of cells, just like anything.
A cancerous tumor is simply a collection of
cells, that are rebelling.
There are trillions of cells in the human
body (estimates range from about 15 to 70
trillion, it’s hard to say for sure).
All these cells are making copies of themselves,
replicating and copying their own DNA all
the time.
And as much as we want it to be, nothing is
perfect.
Sometimes, they just naturally rebel and become
cancer.
Let’s break this down so we all are on the
same page.
Different cells replicate at different rates
-- a red blood cell lives about four months,
a skin cell lives a few weeks, and cells in
the colon only live a few days.
By the time you’re 50, you’ve gone through
about 4600 generations of colon cells!
That’s insane!
By the time you’re 70, you’ve almost had
six and a half thousand new colons… many
millions of cells in the colon dividing six
and a half thousand times with tiny errors
popping up here and there… it’s no wonder
cells become abnormal.
Most of the time in talk about avoiding cancer
you’ll hear, like… don’t eat processed
meat, it’s a carcinogen!
Don’t smoke, the crap in the cigarettes
will give you lung cancer!
Stay out of the sun because UV light will
give you skin cancer!
And that is all true!
But, all those cancers happen for the same
reason.
Simply put, compounds in the smoke, or meat
from the processing, or UV radiation from
the sun -- all mess with DNA in your cells.
When your DNA is screwed with it can sometimes
mutate in such a way that it becomes cancer…
And this can happen even without outside influences.
Mutations happen naturally!
So, two years ago, a paper was published that
said most cancers in the U.S. weren’t caused
by smoking or UV exposure, or lifestyle factors
--
but by regular ol’ DNA replication.
Sometimes cancer just... happens.
The paper says that while 40 percent of cancers
can be prevented with healthy lifestyle choices,
the remainder of cancer causes were inherited
traits or just dumb luck.
Just problems in cell replication.
Skeptical scientists were quick to jump on
this original paper -- in part, because it
was only done in the U.S..
The lives of people in the United States are
not the same as people everywhere -- it’s
not easily generalizable to all the humans
in the world, right?
Right.
So, the scientists heard the critique and
did the whole study again.
It took them two years.
This time they included data from 69 countries,
and added more cancer types!
They found the same thing.
66 percent of cancers just, happen.
And the rest were environmental factors, lifestyle
choices and genetics.
For example: most brain and prostate cancers,
as well as cancers in children are caused
by DNA copy errors -- while some lung cancers
are mostly due to environmental factors!
So, DON’T SMOKE.
But also, yikes for kids.
It’s probably not a surprise, but many doctors
aren’t happy with this paper.
How can we “cure cancer” if cancer is
a normal part of a healthy DNA replication
cycle?
I mean, you can still cut your risk by nearly
half by living healthily, but overall -- cancer
may be just… inevitable, for some.
This is why we need to focus on UNDERSTANDING
cancer on top of the talk of CURING it.
You can cure a cancer as a symptom, but you
can’t cure cancer the mutation without a
lot more science.
If we just think of cancer as this infection,
that happens to people who don’t live right
or who are unlucky, then we’re ignoring
the pure mathematics of DNA replication.
We’re not being honest with ourselves.
Cancer sucks.
But it’s also a normal part of life on this
planet, and just like anything else -- the
sooner we accept it, and understand it, the
better off we’ll all be at figuring out
how we can all just live.
Special thanks to our sponsor, Domain dot
com.
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Get 15% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
If cancer is just cells, and lots of animals
get cancer, I wonder if I’ve ever eaten
cancer?
Have you thought about that?
So gross.
Also gross things I’ve never thought about,
our producer Matt asked “what does human
flesh taste like, and which bit of us is most
nutritious.”
Find out here.
Please subscribe, thanks for watching.
See you later.